[موسيقى]
قسم العرب النجوم الى نجوم استدلاليه وهي
النجوم التي نستدل بها على الجهات واهمها
الجدي الجدي خلوا فوق ورثه المطيه بن
حورها يبدا سهيل اليماني نمشي براي الله
على كل نيه والقدر ناس العقب عشره وثواني
ونجوم حسابيه وهي النجوم التي نستدل بها
على حساب الفصول والمواسم الثريا لحساب
البرد الملزم لحساب الحرف اسماك لحساب
المطر في وجود الثريا بعيده مغيب الشمس
فوق هامت الراس دليل على شده البرد كحالي
ايامنا هذه وجود المرزم قبيله شروق الشمس
شرقا دليل على شده الحرب ووجود اسماك
قبيله شروق الشمس دليل على بدايه الامطار
الصيفيه وبعد مغيب الشمس دليل على بدايه
الامطار الشتويه ان الذي سمك السماء بنى
لنا بيتا دعى امه
وارفع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعامه ينسبون المطر الى النجوم فاول مطر
الوسم يسمى بتروي نسبه الى نجوم الثريا
واخر مطرب الوسم يسمى بالجوز او نسبه الى
نجوم الجوزه فثروي ينبت الفجعه زويدي
والجوزوي ينبت الفقع الخلاسي واول مطر
الصيف يسمى بسمات نسبه الى نجوم السيمات
وهذه احب مواسم الامطار عندهم احبك يا شمس
الزمان وبدره والا مني فيك
فان قليل الحب بالعقل صالح وان كثيرا الحب
بالجهل
فاسدوا
[موسيقى]